you look pretty
what did you say uh I said you look
shitty good night Denise
are you feeling hot
well it's your doctor of love here here
to give you really important Saucy spicy
Flamin Hot dating advice this video is
brought to you by Grill Blazer speaking
of flames we'll get to that in just a
moment first though let's take it away
with some Tinder profiles
Jordan 19 Jordan says Tinder needs a
filter no ugly guys not too short sexy
voice tan strong and muscles and abs not
too much of a French shower and if
you're uglier than your Tinder profile
I'm gonna stop talking to you okay and
this is Jordan
I'll just look at the text
no ugly guys fair enough not too short
yeah okay it's I know for shorter guys
it's tough out there but that's the way
life is sexy voice
that's not one that you usually hear
about but yeah I guess that matters I
guess that matters ladies tan okay not a
white supremacist got it strong in
muscles and abs I think strong would
have just probably on that I like not
too much of a French shower I like this
because
it's a reminder that people like
braggadocio and their men they like a
little Swagger You Know You Gotta Be You
can't just be like a nice simp you got
to be you got to be a little a little
aggressive in some ways you know you got
to be confident I guess not aggressive
you got to be confident and if you're
uglier than your Tinder profile uh
you're you're out okay overall fair
enough it's all physical is the problem
other than not too much of a French
shower so that's the one part where you
say Okay I want this person to be
confident that's great if all you care
about is the physical stuff then you're
probably going to want to be on just a
hookup app is Tinder a hookup app or is
Tinder like a dating get married at oh
no Mr Krabs told me all about you I
don't really know these things because I
just missed dating apps I've never been
on a dating app they were coming around
right around the time the sweet little
Elise and I got back together so I I've
never been on one Stephanie 20 years old
I'm not texting first based women should
not text first I'm learning ASL if me
hating men is an issue to you then you
aren't a man
you're a boy with issues and that's not
attractive my fur baby is named Shia
after Shia LaBeouf wow
this was back when Ben Davies was single
I think this was he was swiping these
people and he must have gotten this one
it's got to be parody I assume it's
parody because there's no there's no
picture on there but there are probably
a lot of feminists today who actually
agree with that third Point that's like
that that Hollywood guy was it the fake
Seth Rogen what's his name Jonah Hill
Jonah Hill was dating this crazy lady
and the crazy lady said I'm an Uber
feminist I'm gonna hang out with a bunch
of dudes and I want to have no
boundaries whatsoever with with any men
and he said okay well then I don't want
to date you because that doesn't sound
very fun she goes you're not even a
feminist he is yeah I guess not I guess
I'm not okay next one about me
demisexual lesbian she her curvy vegan
t4t what does t4t mean
I don't know I don't is it oh and people
date each other but is it
is it like it
does it matter which way it goes
[Music]
I I just don't know
like if I were a dude and I I dressed up
like a chick and I still had my sexual
desires I would want to I would be
attracted to a chick and then if I were
into I guess I would want a chick who
was dressed up a little more masculine I
think I just don't want the real chick
though I wouldn't want like a dude who
pretends to be a chick I think I would
still go for the reality rather than the
appearance but regardless of what it
would be it would matter that
distinction would matter okay so that's
another Femme Bali neurodivergent in a
relationship though Polly so you know
what's the what is a relationship what
is that
uh kinky okay I love kinky that's my new
favorite one oh man I'm so freaking
horny kinky it means that if if you have
any sexual desire that is not shared by
100 of people then you're that's you're
a special thing but that's true of
everybody everybody you know I don't
know you like blonde hair or something
everybody's got something right switchy
is that like you switch like one day
you're a boy one day you're a girl no no
no no no no no
leftist oh wow shocked four times faxed
yeah sounds about right I love movies
music memes walks animation Lefty
podcasts and tabletop games
immunocompromised that immunocomprized
that's funny immunocompromised was just
a thing that was invented in 2020.
it's a euphemism for having weak
Constitution which there's no shame in
having a weak Constitution really I mean
people are born with all sorts of
problems but the immunocompromise what
does that mean disabled with chronic
pain in my hands arms and jaw that's too
bad sorry to hear that chronic fatigue
Celiac and other stuff can eat most
Foods already hear that that's too bad
don't ask me to go to a restaurant I
smoke weed medically yeah uh-huh yeah
right you're on a strict regimen of of
munchies and sticky icky good grief a
cab I don't know what that means oh all
cops are bad
okay about about me all cops are bad oh
hey cool it anyone know what land back
means
no nobody knows what that means I'm
white passing but please no white people
y'all are too much now imagine if the
shoe were on the other foot I hate I
hate even to say it because that's the
Epitaph on The Headstone of conservatism
but imagine if the show were on the
other foot and you know you were a white
guy and you're like hey man I'm white
but please no black people message me I
don't need that you know I don't know
any black people this of course would be
a national incident the president would
give a speech about it but but now you
say I'm I'm white passing but I hate
white people white people are awful okay
right now go to grillblazer.com Knowles
are you tired of waiting ages for your
grill to heat up now you can say goodbye
to those tedious moments of impatiently
watching charcoal burn and say hello to
instant barbecue satisfaction thanks to
our new friends at Grill Blazer real
Blazers Grill guns are designed to do
everything from expertly searing your
Meats to lighting charcoal grills wood
stoves outdoor fireplaces just about
anything you can think of that you need
a high power fire to solve your problem
I would also recommend sparking up
stogies that way especially if your
cigar is like a 400 ring Gauge by 8 18
inch long cigar roll Blazer is a great
way to do it they've got two guns the
grogun basic high propane torch designed
to Light charcoal and wood grills and
smokers burns up to 3 600 Degrees so
it'll probably take care of what you
need 30 inch flame pretty serious and
the SUV gun has a shorter Barrel perfect
for professional Culinary Kitchen uses
from gently caramelizing brulee or other
sugars fruits to rapidly searing steaks
outside on the grill head on over right
now let your grilling Adventures begin
visit growblazer.com use promo code
Knolls for 15 off your order
growblazer.com Knowles promo code nulls
for 15 off your order okay next one
don't know the name CEO of antifa lives
in blank 13 miles away
0.001856 kilometers tall uh black lives
matter sworn enemy of U-Haul culture my
ideal first date an armed proletarian
Insurrection to see is the means of
production and overthrow the ruling
class don't ask me if I'm free this
weekend we live in a fascist police
state none of us are free okay you know
if I were single I don't know if that's
a man or a woman or not but if it were a
woman and I were single I might message
that person because it's either ironic
ironic or is at least kind of self-aware
and funny that's a funny one I got a
kick out of that what is it black lives
matter activism feminism politics
environmentalism that's why CEO of
antifa okay I'd probably go on a date
Hold Up Wait A Minute something ain't
right feminist 24 7. if you ask for
nudes the whole world will know you
asked for nudes over emotional cute AF
fat girl I'm pansexual lame a a b what
is it man I'm so out of it I thought I
think of myself seriously I think of
myself as being about 21 years old but I
realize now I'm an old man even though I
look I've got obviously Riz out the ears
and I'm obviously just full of that drip
for real for real No Cap obviously
that's true but some of these things I
don't really get I constantly have a
headache and I'm sick of everyone but
hey what can you do I don't like sports
that's kind of funny I mean look that
gal needs help you know the hair color
and the attitude and the you know all of
that but I don't know it's kind of funny
I don't know that we would Mash
necessarily I don't know that we'd have
a total alignment on what we're doing in
life and on family and kind of our
vision for our future but because she's
kind of funny she's got like a little
bit of a sense of humor that that's a
sign that not all hope is lost
can fix her
I can fix her you might be able to it's
kind of yeah it's not feminist 24 7.
that's of all of the things that she's
said that's the the least attractive if
I had to pick one uh one one profile I
guess well I'm not a t so this might
disqualify me but I think the one who is
white passing but hates white people I
think and because I think I have a
special place in this person's heart
because I too I'm white passing because
I derive from these Sicilian peoples I I
think that's that's my future
hypothetical Tinder spouse
[Music]
every day